مساء الخير الدين بالنسبه للصلاتين
والحكام سلطه ونصوص ومصالح مهما كانوا
اتقياء في حياتهم الشخصيه
وما فيش دوله في العالم كله
انتو مش انه كل دوله بتحاول تسيطر على
رجال الدين وعلى طريقتهم في تفسير النصوص
المقدسه بحيث تتوافق مع مصالح الدوله
ورؤيه السياسيين
السياسيه يعملوا كده ادراكا منهم لقوه
ونفوذ الدين على حركه الشعوب وسلوك
الافراد وبسبب نفوس الدين نفوذ الدين
واهميته بتسعى اكثر من دوله في الوقت
الحالي
لزعامه العالم الاسلامي الحقيقه اهم هذه
الدول هو التركيه والسعوديه كثير من الناس
ما يعرفوش العلاقه ما بين الاتراك
والسعوديين اتسمت تاريخيا بالعداء الشديد
والدوله العثمانيه هي من قضى على الاماره
الاولى والثانيه او الدوله الاولى
والثانيه الدوله السعوديه الاولى و الدوله
السعوديه الثانيه وعلى سبيل المثال الدوله
السعوديه الاولى اللي كانت في الفتره ما
بين
1747 لا لفت النظر وان 18 انتهت لما ارسل
الباب العالي او السلطان العثماني جيوش
القائد ابراهيم باشا ابن محمد على والى
مصر الى شبه الجزيره العربيه حيث قضى على
الدوله السعوديه الاولى و قتل الكثير من
قادتها والاخر الامير عبد الله السعود
وقتها لو كان امير الدوله في هذا الوقت
الى الى تركيا حيث اعدم في ميدان عام
الدوله السعوديه الثانيه سقطت ايضا بتدخل
من العثمانيين وحلفاؤهم في شبه الجزيره
العربيه الدوله السعوديه الثالثه والموجود
الان لم تقم الا بدعم من الانجليز وعلى ان
قوه الدوله العثمانيه اللي انتهت او سقطت
او تفككت بعد الحرب العالميه الاولى في كل
الاحوال البعض يعتقد ان هذه الصفحه من
التاريخ الطويل ولكن هذه الصفحه قد عادت
مره اخرى هي الصفحه دي من العداء انتهت
وعاد مره اخرى انتهت بسبب تغير الوضع او
الاوضاع في تركيا تركيا بعد الحرب
العالميه الاولى وهذه المتهم تفككت
الامبراطوريه العثمانيه واصبحت تركيا
محصوره في شبه جزيره البلقان وهي التركيه
الحديثه اللي احنا نعرفه والدور الحديثه
اللي احنا نعرفها بدايه من
1923 وال تسعين سنه لم تكن مهتمه كثير
بزعامه العالم الاسلامي بل بالعكس انسحبت
من ال عشرات السنوات كان اهتمامها اكثر
باوروبا بالغرب تاتيكم مثال او مثالين
سريعين على فتور العلاقه بين تركيا وبين
العالم الاسلامي لمده عشرات السنوات بعدما
سقطت ال الدوله او الامبراطوريه العثمانيه
وبدات تركيا الحديثه زي ما بنعرف دلواتي
مثلا لما قامت ال اسرائيل ما اعلنت
اسرائيل قيام دولتها كان التركيه من الدول
التي سارعت بالاعتراف باسرائيل
وعلى فكره ايضا ايران عملت نفس الكلام على
العكس كل الدول العربيه طبعا اللي كانت
حريصه على مش بس انه هي ترفض قيام الدوله
ولا تعترف بها بل شاركت في الحرب بالضغط
تبقى ايضا ما كانش اهتمام كبير بالقضيه
الفلسطينيه وما فتح قنوات اتصال مع منظمه
التحرير الفلسطينيه
الا لاحقا يعني في وقت متاخر في منتصف
السبعينات وصلت العلاقه في ظل هذا الفطور
يعني اتجاه قضايا العالم الاسلامي لفتره
طويله لغايه ما جاء حزب العداله والتنميه
بزعامه رجب طيب اردوغان وبدا الاهتمام
بشكل واضح بالعالم الاسلامي لكن بدون اي
مشاكل لا مع السعوديه ولا غير السعوديه
والسعوديه منحت رجب طيب اردوغان اذن فيصل
لخدمه الاسلام وهي جائزه رفيعه جدا في سنه
الفين وعشره لكن في نفس هذا العام 2010
2011 تغيرت الاوضاع في تركيا ومره اخرى
واصبحت تركيا اكثر اهتماما وحرص للعوده
مره اخرى للعالم الاسلامي ليس كان برا
دوله يعني في معيه اسلامي ولكن قطر اذا
للعالم الاسلامي نتيجه متغيره داخل تركيا
وخارج المتغيرات الى اشرنا البعض ان في
حلقات سابقه تتعلق بان حزب العداله
والتنميه نجح خلال
التسعه والعشره السنوات الاولى من حكمه من
الفين واثنين الفين وعشره في انه هو يقضي
او يدخل او يخضع قول للمؤسسات الكماليه
المقصود نسبه الى مصطفى كمال اتترك
والمؤسسات العلمانيه اللي كانت مسيطره على
تركيا من
1923 واصبح هو اهم اه حزبه اهم المؤسسه
بتركيا عندوش ما عادش عنده معارضه داخل
تركيا للسياسات اللي هي في جوهره سياسات
تقوم على التوجه الى العالم الاسلامي
الامر الثاني انه الاتراك والسياسيين
الاتراك يئسوا من الانضمام الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وبالتالي بدا وادواره على سياسه بديله وهي
العوده للعالم الاسلام المره
بدايه توجه ال اردوغان والاتراك العوده
للعالم الاسلامي وتصادف ذلك مع مرور ثورات
الربيع العربي في 2011 اللي تبنتها
التركيه باعتبارها نقطه انطلاق لرسم نظام
جديد او لفرض رؤيه جديده على كامل منطقه
الشرق الاوسط وهو لنا اشرت اليه في وقت
سابق وخلاصتها انه تمكين الجماعات
الاسلاميه وخصوصا في جماعات الاخوان
المسلمين من الوصول الى السلطه بحيث انه
تحكم هذه الجماعات دول العالم الاسلامي
وتبقى تركيه هي في القلب من هذا العالم او
من هذه الانظمه الاسلاميه
تركيبه انت تتكلم صراحه عن رغبتها في
قياده العالم الاسلامي عن مش مجرد مخطط
موجود في الاضرار وان تشاهده دون الاعلان
عنهم ومثلا رجب طيب اردوغان
في اكتوبر 2013
تركيه هي الدوله الوحيده التي تصلح لزعامه
العالم الاسلامي هو يعني اذا العالم
الاسلامي كلمه زعيم العالم الاسلامي
نسميها ياخذوا وبالتالي يمنح لي مثلا زعيم
مش عارف منظمه
الدول الاسلاميه وال يعني مش لقب رسمي
ولكن هو ظهور دور ده يا دوله تلعبه يا
دوله ما بتلعب دور ب عباره عن ان دوله
تتبنى قضايا العالم الاسلامي
تمارس نفوذ كبير جدا في كل القضايا اللي
تم المسلمين كدول وك اقليات
ينفق عليه يتم التخطيط اليه يعني مثلا
السعوديه منذ الستينات ان سقط عشرات
الملايين من عشرات المليارات للعبه دور ده
في صوره بناء مساجد في كل مكان في العالم
جمعيات خيريه
بعمليه توجهات معينه الانفاق على بعثات
تاتي
للطلاب كل الطلاب المسلمين من كل مكان في
العالم تعمل الدراسه في الجامعات السعوديه
تاسيس قرارات وصحف
لنفس الفكره ديه يعني دي مساله بيتم
التخطيط اليها طيب مواقف معينه اتجاه
قضايا المسلمين سواء كانوا اخلاقيات او
اقليات الى اخره الدور اللي بدا يعملوا
اردوغان وينفق عليه ايضا عشرات المليارات
عشان يعمل نفس الدور اللي كانت وما زالت
تعمل السعوديه و يزاحمها فيه وعلى شافيز
اهمها هو زعيم العالم الاسلامي اللي هو
شايف انه تركيا اصلح لي من السعوديه كان
لازم نركز على مزايا تركيا بالنسبه
للمسلمين ويركز على عيوب الاسره السعوديه
او العيوب المملكه العربيه السعوديه يركز
على مزايا تركيا باعتبارها الخليفه او
الدوله الوريث الطبيعي الخلافه العثمانيه
اخر خلافه لدى المسلمين باعتبار انه كما
يقول يعني السياسيين الاتراك عندهم
الاسلام السمح المعتدل اللي ممكن ما
يتصادم مع الغرب ولا يتصادم مع دول اخرى
ولا يصدر الافكار المتشدده زي ما حصل مثلا
في حداشر سبتمبر او زي الافكار اللي طلعت
القاعده او غيره
وعندها جبال اقليات المختلفه وبالتالي
يعتبر نفسه قادر على قياده العالم
الاسلامي وان يكون همزه وصل ما بين الشرق
والغرب في حاجه
وايضا في اطار مسعى
لتحقيق هذا الهدف
السوريه كريديت يعني شورى السعوديين
ويعرفهم ويقلل من قدرتهم على لعب دور ده
عملنا بطرق كثيره ابرزها حادثه مقتل كمال
خشيه الحكومه السعوديه والمسؤولين
السعوديين تورطوا في هذه
الحادثه البشعه والسعوديين
لكن لكن الاتراك الدوله الوحيده طبعا
ومعها حليفتها قطر اللي ساعد مش بس لعوده
الحقه او لكشف الحقيقه او لاعاده
الحق المقبور كما لقي
اكثر من كده هو تعريف السعوديه والاساءه
بحيث ضربها في مقتل وتولد ي لا تصلح
لزعامه العالم الاسلامي
السعوديين
من سعر الاتراك
لان هما
يلعبون دورهم ولا لانه هناك م ان يستغلوا
حتى
الاتراك عمله ما هو اكثر لاطلاق السعوديه
وبدؤوا يسموها تقريبا عمليا بالقوات
العسكريه والقواعد مش بس اكتفوا القوى
النعمه
مجرد وجود ازمه مع قطر في 2017 السعوديين
وجدوا ان الاطراف بقوا موجودين في قاعده
عسكريه موجوده في قطر لا حدودهم فوجدوا ان
الاتراك موجودين في البحر الاحمر في اكثر
من دوله يعني في جنوب هم بيحاولوا يعني
دور دور القوه النعمه يعني انهم يكونوا
موجودين مثلا في الصومال ويقوم بدور
يعادل الدور اللي السعوديه عاده بتقوم به
في اقامه المدارس في نشره في المناهج
التعليميه في محاوله القيام بدور الوسيط
بين الاطراف المتحاربه لا اذا كان دور
اكثر من كده يعملوا قواعد عسكريه في شرق
افريقيا
عملت معاهده الدفاع المشترك مع الكويت كل
الامور تؤدي الى اصطدام ما بين الدولتين
عاد الصدام مره اخرى اللي كان موجود من
حوالي مائتين سنه وطوي صفحه في التاريخ
الى واقع الواقع الترجمه في صوره صراع في
ملفات كثيره ما بين السعوديه وحلفائها
الامارات ومصر ودول اخرى وما بين تركيا
وحليفتها الوحيده في المنطقه هي قطع ملفات
الى اشرنا اليه المراه اللي فاتت ليبيه
مثلا الى اثنين
بيتصارعوا بالوكاله والصراع في ليبيا ممكن
يكشف لك على طبيعه ان دولتين بيفكروا
الزاي وادى ايه ممكن الدوله لما يكون دوله
تستخدم الاسلام
يعني كاداه من ادوات سياسه الخارجيه ممكن
تبقى مؤثره وقادر ان هي مارس بفوزه خارج
حدودها الاتراك لم احبه يلعبوا دور في
ليبيا دعموا جماعه الاخوان المسلمين اللي
موجوده في الغرب
والسعوديين لما حبوا يتدخلوا في ليبيا
يستخدموا الجماعات السلفيه المعروفه باسم
المداخله او المدى خلال السلفيه المدخليه
اللي موجوده في شرق ليبيا
واللي تدين بالولاء وبين بالطاعه
السعوديه لها نفوذ عليها في شرق ليبيا
تدعموا من قبل السعوديه ال المشير
البلدين بيتصارعوا في اماكن كثيره في
السودان في شرق افريقيا كله زي متسرع بل
كده فى مصر فى 2013
في سوريا والاتراك بيقولوا انه السعوديين
ومع اهم حليفتها الامارات ومصر بيد عم
بيقولوا ال واي بيجي اللي هي وحدات حمايه
الشعب التركي اللي بتعتبرها تركيا جماعه
ارهابيه فيما لا تعتبرها السعوديه
يعني مصر والامارات كذلك
مستمره ما بين الدولتين في عده مرات في
عده ملاحظات اللي تكلم على زعامه العالم
الاسلامي والقضيه
القضيه الاولى انه المساله بالدرجه الاولى
هي قضيه مصالحها نفوس وقد يكون مثال ولم
كل المساله مساله مصالح وسمعناه بالضروره
انه هنا مرافقين لا هو السياسي اذا سياسي
يصلي
يصلي ويذكر ان تقي اولا يكون لكن في كل
الاحوال هو لا يستطيع الا ان يفكر في
الجماعات او في الدين كوسيله من وسائل
القوه الناعمه لبلده قد تكون مثال ان
المال البلدين تشاركها في نفس هذا ال مصر
السعوديه مثلا
رحبت بجماعه الاخوان المسلمين في
الاربعينات والخمسينات والستينات
يعني لاسباب كثيره منها خصوصا في
الخمسينات والستينات
تستخدمهم
لضربه جمال عبد الناصر وتجربه القوميه
العربيه القصه معروفه جدا ف استضافتهم
ومنحت وظائف واقامت الى الاخوه لكن تغير
موقفها من جماعه الاخوان المسلمين بعد
2011 لما قال ان جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ب
تسعى لتقديم نفسها كبديل الانظمه القائمه
بما فيها الاسره السعوديه نفسها
الموجودين في مصر وتونس والى اخره
وبالتالي اعتبرت جماعه الاخوان المسلمين
جماعه ارهابيه
فالجامعه اللي احتضنتها في الخمسينات
والستينات اعتبرتها الانديه طبعا هي
موقفها من الاخوان يعني كيف ترى يتغير منذ
ان تعاطف الاخوان او اي الاخوان غزو صدام
حسين
في التسعينات لكن ساءت تماما بعد احداث
الربيع العربي طيب هل موقف مختلف نائب
يعني مثلا
اولا الداعيه الاسلامي الموجود في تركيا
كان حليفا دي رجب طيب اردوغان حليفا قويا
ودعمه في رحله الى السلطه لكن بمجرد ما
اصبح يمثل من وجهه نظر اردغان دوله موازيه
اعتبر فتح له قولا وجماعته جماعه ارهابيه
وشردهم في كل مكان في تركيا نلاحقهم في كل
مكان حول العالم
وفي الحلقه للاخوان المسلمين بتغير وش وفي
الحالتين اه فتح لاقول افكاره لم تتغير
ولكن المصالح تغير المركزه الثانيه ان
يستفيد من بيت ضرر من صراع الدولتين
اللي بيستفيد يعني مساله فيها نظر نقدر
نقول انه ايران اللي فيها اطلع ايضا
وطموحات في انت تزعم العالم الاسلامي
مستفيده من تضعها للدولتين لكن طبعا موقف
ايران في كل الاحوال محدودا وطرحتها
محدوده
مذهبها يعني او حكم كلها دوله شيعيه لكنها
مستفيده من قطاع هذين الدولتين السنتين
اكيد اسرائيل والولايات المتحده مستفيده
جدا من الخلاف بين الدولتين بحيث انه
دائما يكون محتاجين لاسرائيل والولايات
المتحده اما المتضرر والمتضرر بشده فهو
طبعا اول الدول الاسلاميه اللي بتعاني من
تصارع الدولتين على اراضيه النقطه الثالثه
انه اقولها في الحلقه انه فيه اختلاف في
طبيعه تبنى الدوله السعوديه نسبيا يعني ل
اه
بمفهومها قياده العالم الاسلامي المفهوم
تركيا ل زعامتها للعالم الاسلامي بايجاز
شديد السعوديه
الاوضاع كما هي عليها اما التركيه زعامتها
العالم الاسلامي عاوزه تغير قول الواقع
الموجود زي ما كانت يعني بتتكلم بعد ثورات
الربيع العربي ويبقى السؤال اللي محتاجين
نتوقف عن ماذا لو نجح مشروع رجب طيب
اردوغان ماذا لو افترضنا جدلا انه هذا
المشروع نجح ووصلت جماعات الاسلام السياسي
وخاصه جماعه الاخوان المسلمين الى السلطه
بدون اي نزاع وبدون اي مشاكل واستتبت لهم
الامور الى اي حد له ممكن يخدم قضايا
الاسلام والمسلمين بس والمحتاجين نطرح في
حلقتنا انشاء الله شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]